CALL TO MAKE, WE WILL BRING IT
TO YOU.
TUCKER, BACK TO YOU.
>> Tucker: BRET AND MARTHA,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
TONIGHT IT CLD BE
BERNIE SANDERS LAST STAND AS OF
TOMORROW MORNING, HALF OF THE
DELEGATES IN THE DEMOCRATIC RACE
WILL HAVE BEEN AWARDED.
IF SANDRA SUFFERS A LOPSIDED
DEFEAT IN THE NEXT FEW HOURS,
HIS PATH TO THE NOMINATION WILL
ESSENTIALLY DISAPPEAR.
IF THAT HAPPENS, MILLIONS OF
BERNIE SUPPORTERS WILL WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING OUTRAGED AND
DISAPPOINTED.
THEY WILL BELIEVE SANDERS HAS
THE NOMINATION STOLEN FROM HIM
BY A RUTHLESS DEMOCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT FEARFUL OF CHANGE.
TO SOME EXTENT, THEY WILL BE
RIGHT.
THERE IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
REASON BERNIE SANDERS APPEARS TO
BE LOSING TONIGHT.
HE IS WEAK.
SANDERS IS A SOCIALIST BOMB
THROWER WHO TRADES WITH FIDEL
CASTRO BUT MOSTLY TALK IN THE
END.
UNDERNEATH IT ALL BERNIE SANDERS
MAY BE THE LAMEST REVOLUTIONARY
EVER.
TWICE IN A ROW, SANDERS HAS
TRIED TO WIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
TWICE IN A ROW THEY RIGGED THE
GAME AGAINST HIM.
IN 2016, LEAKED EMAIL SHOWS
DEMOCRATIC OFFICIALS OPENLY
MOVING FOR HILLARY CLINTON, HIS
OPPONENT.
THE PRIMARY DEBATES IN THAT YEAR
THE WAY THEY THOUGHT WOULD HURT
SANDERS.
THE DNC ENTERED INTO A JOINT
FUND-RAISING AGREEMENT WITH HIS
OPPONENT, THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
REMARKABLE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY DID MORE TO
THE PROCESS FOUR YEARS AGO THEN
VLADIMIR PUTIN EVEN ATTEMPTED TO
DO.
SANDERS WAS NEVER GOING TO WIN.
WHEN HE FINALLY DID LOSE,
SANDERS DID NOT EVEN COMPLAIN
ABOUT IT.
HE DUTIFULLY SHOWED UP AT THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION AND
ENDORSED HILLARY CLINTON.
WHEN THE EXTENT OF HER TREACHERY
BECAME CLEAR IN THE LEAKED
EMAILS, SANDERS CAMPAIGN FOR
HER.
HILLARY WAS NOT GRATEFUL FOR IT.
SHE BASHES HIM EXTENSIVELY AND A
NEW DOCUMENTARY AND NOT JUST HIS
POLICY BUT PERSONALLY CLAIMING
NOBODY LIKES HIM.
SO WHAT DID SANDERS LEARN FROM
ALL OF THIS?
NOT A SINGLE THING.
A WEEK AGO THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY COALESCED WITH
STUNNING SPEED AROUND JOE BIDEN
AND YOU ARE WATCHING THE RESULTS
TONIGHT.
IT IS NOT AS IF THE
ESTABLISHMENT PREFERS BIDEN WHO
IS FREELY WORKING TOWARDS IN
COMPETITIVE HE DID.
THEY JUST DESPISED
BERNIE SANDERS AND DESPERATE TO
STOP HIM.
THEY WOULD PICK ANYBODY, AND
THEY DID AND IT WORKED.
SANDERS GOT CRUSHED ON SUPER
TUESDAY.
AND ACTUALLY WHO WANTED TO WIN
WOULD HAVE PAUSE THE DAY AFTER
TO REASSESS HIS CAMPAIGN.
FOR SANDERS, THIS WEEK WAS THE
TIME TO TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING WHILE WE ARE
ALL WATCHING.
THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINATING SYSTEM
IS ROTTEN AND CORRUPT.
AND THOROUGHLY BIDEN IS NOT
CLEAR FOR GOVERNING THE COUNTRY
LET ALONE A PRESS CONFERENCE.
THE PROCESS IS SHOCKING HIM A
FRAUD NOT TO MENTION INCREDIBLY
CYNICAL AND RECKLESS.
THE ESTABLISHMENT DOESN’T CARE
WHO THE PRESIDENT IS.
THEY JUST WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN
IT IS SOMEONE THEY CAN CONTROL
WHO WON’T RAISE THEIR TAXES.
SANDERS COULD HAVE SETTLED THAT
AND SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE IT IS
TRUE.
INSTEAD, HE DEFENDED JOE BIDEN.
WATCH.
>> THE QUESTION OF JOE BIDEN’S
MENTAL ACUITY IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT JUST COMES UP ANYWHERE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BROUGHT THIS UP,
INCLUDING SENATOR CORY BOOKER
WHO ENDORSED JOE BIDEN TODAY.
>> I WILL NOT GO THAT LEVEL OF
ATTACKING.
JOE AND I, THAT IS FOR PEOPLE TO
DECIDE.
ALL I CAN SAY, JOE AND I HAVE
SIGNIFICANT POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES.
AND I’M NOT GOING TO MAKE
PERSONAL ATTACKS ON JOE.
THAT IS NOT WHAT I DO.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO ACCORDING TO BERNIE SANDERS,
WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO TALK ABOUT
THE ONE THING ALL OF US CAN SEE
CLEARLY EVERY DAY.
THE DEMOCRATIC FRONT RUNNER IS
FAILING.
HE’S NOT CAPABLE OF TAKING THE
JOB HE’S RUNNING FOR.
HIS STAFF IS DESPERATE TO KEEP
HIM FROM INTERACTING WITH THE
PUBLIC FOR MORE THAN 2 MINUTES.
BY THE WAY, IT IS NOT A PARTISAN
TALKING POINT.
IT IS TRUE.
IT IS AN OBSERVATION THAT
EVERYONE PAYS ATTENTION HAS.
AND IT IS SAD, REALLY SAD.
IT IS DAMAGING SINCERELY.
BUT IN RESPONSE A ANY OF THE
SPIRIT SHUT UP AND RAPIDLY
DECLINING COMMUNICATION SKILLS
IS A "PERSONAL ATTACK."
IT IS PRETTY OBVIOUS SANDERS
DOESN’T WANT TO WIN IS A MAN WHO
THINKS IT’S MORE NOBLE TO FAIL
THEM TO SUCCEED.
YOU WERE WATCHING A PROFESSIONAL
LOSER.
SANDERS IS ALL BUT ADMITTING
THAT NOW AND ALREADY PROMISED TO
BACK BIDEN IF BIDEN LEADS THE
NOMINATION.
AND HE WILL NOT CONTEST THE
CONVENTION IF BIDEN FALLS SHORT
OF A DELICATE MAJORITY, WATCH.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY IT
TURNS OUT VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
WILL HAVE MORE DELEGATES THAN
YOU DO HEADING INTO THE
CONVENTION, WOULD YOU DROP OUT?
>> HE WILL WIN.
WE WILL RUN AND I SUSPECT WE
WILL RUN THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO VOTE.
BUT IF BIDEN HAS DEMENTIA --
>> THAT IS TRUE WHETHER OR NOT
HE HAS THE MAJORITY OR
PLURALITY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: OH, ABSOLUTELY SAYS
BERNIE SANDERS, ABSOLUTELY.
PATHETIC, ACTUALLY.
REAL REVOLUTIONARIES GO TO THE
WALL FOR WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
BERNIE SANDERS WON’T EVEN GO TO
THE CONVENTION.
BECAUSE THAT IS WHO
BERNIE SANDERS IS AND THAT’S WHO
HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
BACK IN 2015 AT A RALLY IN
SEATTLE, TWO DEMONSTRATORS TOOK
THE MIC FROM SANDERS WHILE HE
WAS TRYING TO SPEAK.
RATHER THAN TAKE BACK HIS OWN
PODIUM, SANDERS TOOK A SIDE BY A
SCOLDED CHILD AND CALLED UP THE
EVENT ALTOGETHER WITHOUT EVEN
FINISHING HIS SPEECH.
IMAGINE DOING THAT YOURSELF.
IMAGINE HOW MUCH SELF LOATHING
YOU WOULD HAVE.
WOULD YOUR KIDS LOOK YOU IN THE
FACE?
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT HE KEPT DOING IT.
LESS THAN TWO MONTHS AGO SANDERS
SUPPORTERS DID WHAT HE WOULDN’T
DO, TOLD THE TRUTH ABOUT
JOE BIDEN.
SHE CALLED HIM CORRUPT AND SHE
DID A POOR REASON.
FOR DECADES A PAID LACKEY OF THE
CREDIT CARD COMPANIES.
BUT SANDERS WOULDN’T PLAY ALONG.
HE APOLOGIZED FOR WHAT HIS
SURROGATE SAID AND CLAIMED
JOE BIDEN WAS ETHICALLY PURE
APPEARED SANDERS ATTACKED HIS
OWN SURROGATE FOR TELLING THE
TRUTH.
SO WHAT DID SANDERS GET IN
RETURN FOR DOING THAT?
MORE ATTACKS AND OF COURSE YOU
CAN GUESS IT, THEY CONTINUED TO
DENOUNCE HIM IN SUPPORTERS AS
SEXIST, BULLIES, LOSERS AND THEY
ARE STILL DOING IT TONIGHT AND
THEY WILL KEEP IT UP UNTIL
THAT -- UNTO THE GENERATIONS.
PERSONAL ATTACKS IS WHAT THEY DO
BEST.
WHERE IS BERNIE IN THIS?
SECRETLY ENJOYING THIS AND
LOSING AND HE IS IDEOLOGICALLY